[Music]
investigations are still ongoing into
the failures operation odin sword male
missions resulted in the death of twelve
navy seals
lieutenant commander james reese can you
outline the details of your mission
they knew we were coming regarding the
audio logs you went dark on coms roughly
four mics in
why
that's not how it went down
you okay yeah i'm fine
headaches paranoia
memory confusion
we're gonna get through this okay
tell me what happened somebody fed us
bad intellect it's a setup
if i'm right we need to act on this i
need names if there's connection to you
and your men
i'll find it
answers
or blood
blood
where's james reese is it true your
fugitive is a navy seal there's a bunch
of people tracking you right now so just
lay low
i have 12 men flying on the caskets
right now
this is personal
oh you wanted it on the fray now
you're in the battlefield
there's evil in this world likes it
which you can't possibly imagine
james
take lucy get her out of the house now
i'm not gonna tell you again
stay off my list
[Music]
you